[Musique]
et cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
richard wehrli bonjour bonjour merci
d'être sur ce plateau vous êtes encore
pour quelques semaines le correspondant
permanent en france du grand quotidien
suisse le temps dans lequel on vous lit
vous êtes avec nous ce lundi et ce sera
le cas tous les lundis jusqu'à la
présidentielle pour commenter cette
campagne électorale ici en france enfin
non pas avec vous tous les lundis mais
c'est ce qu'on va faire tous les lundis
et je signale aussi ce podcast
hebdomadaire que vous animez qui
s'appelle comment va la france vous qui
la connaissent et bien richard wehrli
vous trouvez qu'elle va comment
justement la france écoutez il faut je
crois qu'il faut faire une différence
entre l'écho médiatique général qui est
un écho de fractures de difficultés de
ressentiment de passions identitaires et
la réalité du pays notamment la réalité
économique parce que rappelons le quand
même pour l'instant ça va plutôt bien
les chiffres sont meilleurs qu'on ne
pouvait le penser le chômage a baissé
donc il faut bien avoir en tête quand on
regarde cette campagne présidentielle
notamment parce que c'est le miroir
actuelle ces deux éléments d'un côté la
passion de l'autre peut-être une
situation qui est meilleur qu on le
pense vu de paris et vu des plateaux de
télévision vous important dans votre
nouveau livre qui sort dans quelques
semaines chez grasset qui s'appelle la
france contre elle-même vous décrivez un
pays rongé par des antagonismes
instrumentaliser une france empêcher
empêché de quoi je crois que la france
est empêchée au fond d'être elle-même
sssa l'objet de ce livre alors c'est un
livre un peu particulier parce que je
raconte les fractures de 2022 au miroir
d'une grande fracture qui fut celle de
1940 et de la ligne de démarcation que
j'ai suivi la ligne de démarcation de
l'époque et où je joue j'ai vu qu'en
fait il y a une extraordinaire capacité
française de solidarité une
extraordinaire capacité de rassemblement
quand une énorme crise survient il n'y a
pas eu sans doute pire crise que celle
de 1940 non voilà le constat c'est que
le pays encore une fois il est
ambivalent et c'est ça qui le rend
difficile à décrypter toujours d'un côté
le pays en fusion les colères qui sont à
fleur de peau on le voit récemment avec
le convoi de la liberté à nouveau et les
gilet jaune qui pourrait revenir sur le
devant de la scène mais de l'autre un
pays presque immobile tranquille qui
finalement vis à vis dehors des passions
parisienne et métropolitaine la france
qui s'apprête donc à se choisir un
nouveau président de la république pour
cinq ans le premier tour c'est dans 55
jours vous en avez suivi des campagnes
présidentielles pas que présidentielle
d'ailleurs ici en france pour le temps
qu'est ce que celle ci a de particulier
pour l'observateur que vous êtes je
pense qu'elle a deux choses d'abord elle
a un président sortant qui apparaît en
tout cas dans les sondages plutôt en
forme ça c'est assez nouveau souvent le
président sortant il était il est en
difficulté manuel macro la pandémie lui
a donné un tremplin en quelque sorte
bien évidemment il ya beaucoup de colère
dans le pays mais il est plutôt perçu
comme quelqu'un qui pour l'instant a les
cartes en main ça c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose c'est évidemment
la surprise du moment et là surprise -
elle s'appelle eric zemmour il y a
toujours à chaque élection
présidentielle en france une surprise là
qui pouvait penser que celui qui était
polémiste dans un dans différents
quotidiens et sur une chaîne de
télévision réussir et en quelques
semaines à monter ce qui est aujourd'hui
une campagne quand même assez
impressionnante où l'on voit qu'il est
vraiment en ordre de bataille qu'il est
capable de bousculer l'ordre établi et
de l'étranger justement quel regard on
porte sur eric zemmour et cette
surprise je pense que c'est un
personnage extrêmement français c'est en
tout cas la l'impression qu'il donne il
est extrêmement français d'abord par ses
références et il en abuse vous savez les
références historiques littéraires en
permanence mais il est aussi français
parce que ce qu'ils animent ce sont deux
sentiments très français d'une part
leurs sentiments anti immigrés alors
partout dans le monde il y a toujours
des tensions avec l'immigration mais en
france ça a pris une tournure
extrêmement dramatique et d'autre part
chérif ghemmour il ya ce miroir de
l'histoire l'algérie française vichy ça
ce sont des épisodes très français qui
n'appartiennent qu'à ce pays l'événement
politique du week-end c'était le premier
meeting national de valérie pécresse
était hier à paris valérie pécresse dont
la campagne patine jusqu'ici qu'est ce
que vous en avez retenu alors moi j
étais donc au zénith de paris ce que
j'en ai retenu c'est que pour l'instant
sur la base de ce premier meeting je ne
crois pas qu'elle est en train de suivre
la voie qu'avait indiqué les
observateurs tout le monde pensait aux
fonds qu'elle allait aller chasser sur
les terres des les zemmour est la
meilleure preuve c'est qu'elle avait à
ses côtés ricciotti qu'elle a battue
mais qui est tenant d'une ligne de
droite très dure il me semble plutôt
qu'elle elle mis sur la droite
raisonnable elle va plutôt sur la base
de ce pognon et y aller chasser sur les
terres des manuels macro elle pense que
son électorat de droite va tenir parce
que le parti tient autour d'elle
d'ailleurs tous les hiérarques du parti
étaient présents donc pour moi c'est
intéressant elle va projeter une image
de compétence une image de capacités à
gouverner est-ce que ce sera suffisant
on le verra pour l'instant je ne la vois
pas débordé sur sa droite en quelque
sorte il ya eu quand même des critiques
sur la sur la forme
il revenir il ya eu cette intervention
qu'on va écouter on en reparle juste
après
serons-nous une nation unie ou une
nation éclaté
face à ces questions vitales pas de
fatalité ni aux grandes et classement ni
au grand remplacement
le fait que la candidate du parti
républicain invalides richard wehrli en
employant dans son discours cette
théorie complotiste dite du grand un
remplacement qui a été celle entre
autres choses de la tuerie de
christchurch en nouvelle zélande vous ne
pensez pas que c'est là pour le coup une
espèce de zemmour isation de la campagne
de valérie pécresse je pense qu'il y à
des marqueurs qu'elle est obligée
d'avoir aujourd'hui est le marqueur du
grand emplacement puisque c'est la
formule consacrée il est finalement
obligé pour séduire la partie droite de
son électorat mais il y a tout le reste
du meeting qu'il ne faut pas oublier et
il y a le programme qui va venir et moi
j'ai été frappé dans l'entourage de
valérie pécresse après le meeting tout
le monde a insisté sur le programme aux
faux son calcul c'est elle ne veut pas
être dans la surenchère
maintenant même si elle utilise des
termes comme grands emplacements qui
mais qui n'est pas quelque chose qui
n'est pas de l'ordre du détail c'est
quand même une théorie complotiste
d'extrême droite qui était
théorisée par c'est absolument ce que
vous dites mais il faut reconnaître que
dans le champ politique aujourd'hui
c'est devenu un thème c'est devenu un
thème de discussion un thème de débat
soit pour dire que c'est vrai puisque
d'irriguer moore soit pour dire que
c'est faux ce que disent un certain
nombre de gens même la majorité des gens
eu des gars aux statistiques et à la
réalité donc on peut le regretter on
peut regretter que l utilise ce terme
mais pour l'instant je n'y vois pas de
sa part je dirais une effusion du côté
d'eric zemmour je pense qu'elle va se
garder peut-être que je me trompe
évidemment mais sur la base de ce que
j'ai vu hier elle va se garder de trop
pencher de ce côté de la balance tout
simplement parce qu'elle sait sans doute
que pour elle ce serait le baiser de la
mort parce qu'à ce moment là toute une
partie de l'électorat de droite modérée
partira immédiatement vers emmanuel
macron c'est difficile pour elle le
chemin il était nu mais elle va essayer
de le tenir sur la base d'un programme
encore une fois qu'on ne connaît pas
pour l'instant la stratégie politique du
grand écart entre la droite modérée que
peut incarner un edouard philippe et
celle d'eric ciotti et ce discours était
à l'image de ce grand écart au départ
très très rude enfin très très à droite
et à la fin en tapant sur les
extrémistes oui mais regardez par
exemple elle utilise la formule grand
remplacement mais elle n'est là bord pas
dessus dire qu'elle a quand même encore
une fois ce n'est c'était son premier
meeting il faut le prendre comme une
espèce de direction donnée et cette
direction c'est celle encore une fois de
la gouvernance de la capacité à mener la
france vous savez sa fameuse phrase elle
est une femme qui fait qui fera elle a
utilisé le thème de la france de l'ordre
donc je ne sais pas si ça sera suffisant
encore une fois ce sera très difficile
quand on regarde les sondages mais elle
semble vouloir s'en tenir à cette ligne
qui est celle de l'ancien ministre la
femme d'expérience à qui vous pouvez
faire confiance parce qu'elle appliquera
ce qu'elle a dit alors que d'autres
candidats plus populiste plus
extrémistes affiche des intentions
qu'ils ne pourront de toute manière pas
tenir quelques mots de ce convoi a dit
de la liberté qui a tenté en vain de
bloquer paris ce week-end et qui se
dirige en en parlait dans le journal en
ce moment vers bruxelles est ce qu'ils
arriveront jusqu'au siège des
institutions européennes pas certain
toujours est il qu'il a rappelé au
souvenir plutôt mauvais souvenir du
gouvernement cette colère sociale qui
s'était exprimée lors de la crise et
gilet jaune il ya deux ans quel regard
vous portez sur cette résurgence est
selon vous cette colère sociale comment
va-t-elle s'exprimer va-t-elle
s'exprimer d'ici deux mois moi je
m'interroge quand même beaucoup sur le
calendrier alors certes il y à la
parenté avec ce qui s'est passé au
canada vous en avez parlé tout à l'heure
dans votre reportage dont camion de la
liberté cana aujourd'hui camion de la
liberté français voire européen cela dit
on est à quelques jours de l'annoncé de
candidature officielle des manuels macro
et comme par hasard on revoit des scènes
de violence dans paris moi j'étais
samedi aux champs elysées la place de
l'étoile était complètement barricadé
par la police mais on revoyait ce qu'on
avait vu à l'époque des gilet jaune
c'est à dire les nuages de gaz
lacrymogènes les affrontements dans
certaines rues des champs-elysées tout
ça au milieu des touristes et du trafic
de voitures normales donc je m'interroge
quand même sur cette coïncidence ce qui
est certain c'est que si on voyait la
violence si on devait voir la violence
de ce type revenir notamment dans les
rues de paris ou dans les rues d'autres
grandes villes maintenant ce serait une
très mauvaise nouvelle pour emmanuel
macron parce qu'à ce moment-là ça
contredirait ce que je disais avant il
n'apparaîtrait plus comme le président
qui a réussi à tenir en quelque sorte le
pays mais comme celui qui est incapable
de le tenir donc là il y a un calendrier
politique extrêmement difficile et les
gilet jaune de leur côté en tout cas
ceux qui mènent ces canons de la liberté
même s'ils ont été empêchés de perturber
vraiment la capitale ce week-end ils
vont sans doute réessayer et puis à
gauche pour finir ce tour d'horizon
rapide
on navigue encore à vue un jean luc
mélenchon tenait son disque son meeting
hier à montpellier je crois qu'il a même
pas utiliser le mot gauche lors de son
de son discours a montpellier on est sur
une gauche fractionné morcelé qu'est ce
que ça dit du débat démocratique
français alors pour le coup je n'étais
pas à montpellier je n'ai pas encore
suivie de meeting de jean luc mélenchon
ce qui est frappant c'est que bon ça on
le savait il est bon en meeting il il
franchit bien toutes les étapes et on
est peut-être en train d'assister à ce
qu'on a vu en 2017 rappelez-vous hier
une télévision donner cette ces chiffres
donc en février 2017 jean luc mélenchon
est à 10 ou 11 % des suffrages il
termine au 1er tour à 19,6 pour cent
juste derrière françois fillon est ce
qu'on ne va pas assister à une remontée
ada de jean luc mélenchon sur la base
d'un vote utile de gauche finalement si
vous êtes un électeur français de gauche
aujourd'hui à qui vous pouvez donner
votre voix de manière utile à priori à
jean luc mélenchon même si le personnage
ne vous plaît pas tellement et ce qu'il
risque de faire et c'est ce qu'on a vu à
montpellier c il va justement gommer
tous les aspects de sa personnalité
qu'ils peuvent diviser notamment son
soutien à certains régimes autoritaires
et cetera pour essayer de rassembler son
peuple de gauche donc il ya une équation
mélenchon et d'après ce qu'on dit du
côté de l'elysée on est très attentif à
ça parce qu'on croit que l'électorat de
gauche ne va pas se disperser voir se
réfugier dans l'abstention mais qu'il
sera bien présent et derrière lui en
quelques mois c'est le naufrage écoutez
on ne voit pas d'autre candidat alors il
ya bien sûr yannick jadot mais moi j'ai
toujours sur la base de mon expérience
suisses et européennes j'ai toujours de
la peine à inclure les écologistes dans
la gauche parce qu'il ya des écologistes
qui sont plutôt centriste qui ne sont
pas nécessairement de gauche et yannick
jadot si vous creusez chez les jeunes
notamment les jeunes ne se définissent
pas comme électeurs de gauche ou de
droite ils sont juste écolos ils votent
pour le climat etc et puis il y à fabien
roussel dont on voit qu'il fait une
percée au moins dans les médias pour le
reste c'est extrêmement difficile il y a
évidemment le calvaire parce qu'on peut
pas employer d'autres mots calvaire dans
les sondages d'anne hidalgo et en ce qui
concerne christiane taubira la grande
question des parrainages puisqu'il
semble qu'elle est mal parti pour
obtenir les fameuses 500 signatures en
deux mots vraiment en suisse ça
intéresse beaucoup cette campagne
française bruxelles faisait la une du
temps ce matin
évidemment parce que pour deux raisons
simples d'abord parce qu'en suisse
romande en suisse francophone le
spectacle politique français passionne
on a un régime parlementaire beaucoup
plus calme et ensuite parce que l'enjeu
est déterminant la france est un des
grands voisins de la suisse et quand la
france va bien en général une bonne
partie de la suisse notamment
francophone va bien aussi merci beaucoup
à richard vers lille est revenu ce matin
sur le plateau de paris